[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Saki on we
have another very thought-provoking
topic we're talking about today I mean a
very nuanced driven way we're gonna be
talking about sociopathy and Jake Paul
the idea of a maverick a sociopath a
psychopath and a megalomaniac so we'll
be kind of illustrating out the spectrum
and also just remember take a breath get
into your body in your heart relax we're
we talking about this in a very calm and
nuanced driven way and we hope that we
inspire other people to have these sort
of multivariate and nuanced and calm
discussions about these very
thought-provoking topics so in order to
start we have to actually explain how
complex human behavior is it's really
difficult explaining in a nutshell and
there have been a hundred plus billion
people that have lived and died before
us today to build this world that we
have now that means they had different
experiences different perceptions of
reality and now today with technologies
and attention economies that's added a
whole new set of variables to the
equation so there are people that have
studied tens of thousands of mental
states but that doesn't mean they have a
good understanding of how new variables
of technology and attention at times
have changed the landscape of mental
states and that's the same thing for
people who understand tech and attention
economies but don't understand the deep
human psyche so I'm attempting to come
at this from a nuanced driven
multivariate common reductionist
approach where I'll be outlining what I
feel are the most pressing issues and
examples around the topic this is a
serious issue for some people and it
needs to be treated as such for others
it's a little more about being different
in a conformist society and let's jump
into unpacking this more so first things
first there is definitely something
strange we'll get to definition
these forth words on the spectrum but
there's something very strange about
putting yourself on camera for even just
a couple of people to watch like right
now let alone for millions of people to
watch there's something strange about
what that does to the mind this impacts
the mind and soul in ways that are
svelte and that we need to understand
more because when you do something like
put out clickbait thumbnails or
clickbait video titles or clickbait
article titles or clickbait newspaper
headlines or magazine covers people are
just trying to grab attention this is a
limited cake it's a zero-sum game there
are only seven and a half billion people
that are awake and they're awake for 16
hours a day you multiply seven and a
half by sixteen you get a hundred twenty
billion hours of attention every single
day and that's all you get it's a
zero-sum game the cake so if someone
takes if I'm taking your attention right
now that means Facebook or Instagram or
someone else is not getting your
attention so that means my slice of the
cake got bigger and there's got smaller
so it's a zero-sum game in that sense so
that's why all of these
attention-grabbing mechanisms that are
being made are also deep brew deeply
rooted in the fact that that's how they
make money
people make money based on ads i we here
at simulation care so much about
inspiring people to build the future and
rebirthing the public intellectual and
scaling our impact and we don't need to
do so through advertisements in paid
subscriptions to this content no we need
to do this by disseminating this as
widely as possible and getting people
inspired in that sense so really think
about what the attention economy is
doing to catalyze people's behavior in
this direction of of click baby so
technology has built a lot of trust so
we leave these digital footprints and we
are now racing against other content
creators for these views and attention
so we can stay relevant and grow faster
than others so this does build up some
sort of sociopathy in some content
creators because they're doing their
best to do something you
dangerous or lacking regard for their
own safety or for the rights or safety
of others in order to go viral and stay
relevant right now we're not doing
anything dangerous or violating the
rights of people this is a very
educational channel but there are other
channels where people are lighting cars
on fire and they're putting thumbnails
that say like check out how we lit a car
on fire and stuff like that and that
puts people at risk which we'll get into
more below
so let's actually let's actually
consider how youtubers make content to
grow these sort of audiences in ways
that are dangerous versus youtubers that
grow content that grow audiences that
make content that's educational it's a
very big difference here so let's define
these words now us to find sociopaths
and Psychopaths first and this is
through a compilation of psychology and
medical online sites so sociopaths tend
to lie break laws act impulsively
aggressively lack regard for their own
safety or for the safety rights of
others this is most closely represented
by antisocial personality disorder a SPD
and it may begin to show symptoms in
childhood but the condition can be
diagnosed until adolescence or adulthood
and symptoms may lessen with age
Psychopaths have persistent antisocial
behavior impaired empathy and remorse
and bold disinhibited egotistical traits
classified as personality disorder as
well so I think the biggest distinction
there between sociopaths Psychopaths is
the persistence with the psychopath of
the antisocial behavior and also the
very bold egotistical traits and that
impaired empathy so the fact that
empathy is really impaired as well as
the ego is really high so that's kind of
the difference with sociopaths and
Psychopaths for from what I'm
understanding and that this sort of
tendency to lie or break laws or act
impulsively they're aggressively is
something that is a little bit different
that we're gonna unpack a bit here and I
think we need two more definitions for
the spectrum that we're describing so
the next definition is megalomaniac it's
a pathological egotist someone with a
psychological disorder with symptoms
like delusions of grandeur up
with power and immittance
all-knowingness so let's have so we're
now illustrating this the spectrum where
we have sociopath
we have psychopath we have megalomaniac
and then we have a maverick a maverick
is an unorthodox independent minded
person individualist or eccentric
unusual so now we have maverick
sociopaths Psychopaths megalomaniac okay
so if you're a maverick you're just
different you just behave differently
this is a spectrum so it's not binary
some people are very sociopathic that
Teeter on psychopathy some people are
barely sociopathic at all some of the
most well-known figures in our world are
megalomaniacs and this is evident and
their behavior with fame wealth and
disregard for others completely so back
at this understanding of Mavericks and
socio slightly sociopathic people I
don't like all of societal constructs
and I feel like some of the societal
laws we've constructed push conformity
of thinking and that's bad for diverse
innovative thought so some people
pushback on the societal laws and end up
somewhere in this spectrum in many ways
these people don't have a disorder they
see society has a conformity issue and
they may want to bring novel sometimes
playful sometimes disruptive ideas to
the monoculture of behavior I think this
is actually very common in society
people that see themselves as unorthodox
independent minded eccentric people that
see societal laws are constructs and say
that I don't want to follow those I want
to have innovative thinking that could
actually move society forward and so a
lot of entrepreneurs in that sense are
slightly sociopathic they see the way
that the current system is and they want
to say that those laws and those
constructs aren't that good and I know
how to make them better and when they do
when people like them that's when they
get big we really have to think about it
on this spectrum so then there's also
technically some people struggle with
mental illness on the spectrum where
they can't actually feel other people's
emotions and an inhibition like this can
lead to serious prom
that person can't control their ego in
his power-hungry they could begin using
other people in their chess game of
civilization that they're trying to win
they could become skilled actors
expressing empathy when they really feel
nothing in order to manipulate this
leads to serious problems and this is a
serious mental issue but sometimes
normal people that are running
businesses feel this way for short
bursts of time and they're not crazy
they just try their best to counter the
feelings of power and ego rising and
feel like they are using other people to
build their dreams with loving and
caring thoughts for people that are
helping them and how what they're
building will hopefully help them
transcend some people can even have
these disorder thoughts arise in faith
so here I'm describing how people that
are building businesses see that yeah
they're actually having people work with
them on building the business and
sometimes they get these thoughts that
come to their mind about how oh my gosh
this is ego this is power and they start
feeling different because of that and
they have to do their best to transcend
their ego so again sometimes you can go
up the spectrum in a moment of success
let's say and then you have to transcend
your ego and move off the spectrum
completely and just be completely
transcendent of it it's very difficult
to do that and that it happens in bursts
of time as well so so again it's not
binary and this one's really crazy but
people with fame power influence great
wealth may potentially gain feelings of
superiority more frequently and need to
do even more work to calm their egos and
transcend that feeling of superiority
and this is extremely difficult to do
and let me give you this example when
people want to take photos of with you
everywhere you go where everyone wants
to email you to work with you your times
being pulled in so many different
directions some famous people have even
said I don't know if you'd want to be me
and imagine if you can't turn this off
this means walking around and going
everywhere and not being able to be at
peace because everybody's always trying
to get something from you again this
fame power influence wealth being
nonstop not being able to normally walk
around without being recognized unless
you go to a foreign place where nobody
knows you that becomes a strange feeling
after a while
where everything you say online is under
deep scrutiny by the media and public
and people are sound biting you and
making it seem like you meant things
that you really didn't mean this is a
nightmare at times your sense of privacy
is gone your kids are unable are being
manipulated at times for people's
personal gain towards you it's a big
mental soup that people get put into
position like this so when you get into
a high-ranking position somewhere on
YouTube I feel that things get even more
complicated because you get in all this
mess plus you have to keep creating
content keep your viewership engaged
sharing growing keep them buying
merchandise and following your spin-off
accounts and this is where a lot of the
social issues can come into play if
you're doing things like setting cars on
fire in public settings then posting
those videos to attract viewership that
car was set on fire might have been in a
neighborhood where it was tough for
someone to breathe or it scared old
people or children or god forbid caught
a tree on fire and needed the department
called and could have injured someone or
you could have been injured or some of
your friends could have been injured in
doing the stunt there are plenty of
videos of people doing insane things
where they are teetering with life and
death and that is their choice and there
are even videos where people die from
doing these stunts and what is that for
us a wake-up call do they leave us early
because of the viral video age or was
this the warning they were supposed to
leave really stay with that feeling for
a moment were they really teetering with
life and death to try and get views this
is really the world that we're building
teetering with people's health that is
not even their own there in their
livelihood their injury some people have
even proposed this a change in social
metrics on accounts not seeing likes or
followers and equating that to being
able to see how much money people have
in their bank account stamped on their
t-shirt whatever the augmentation we
pick we must soon act because our morals
and ethics are making changes to better
things with our wisdom over technology
it should not just key it's just not
keeping up and letting it run rampant is
going to cause them any more unforeseen
issues but also possibly some successes
with great people to see things in new
ways and flourish in that sense so again
we need to augment our morals and ethics
to deal with this age of technology and
the attention economy and we also need
to be okay with some Mavericks and kind
of slight sociopaths of changing some
sort of the societal fabrics for the
better so technology and limits and
attention and time for humans alive are
causing a new wave of narcissism and
placing people on the spectrum is not
easy nor is placing myself and it takes
a lot of reflection to be completely
honest and and to self work to transcend
these feelings of superiority be
skeptical when you see videos that seem
like they're luring you into watch how
educational will this video be how true
is this article with this really catchy
headline how many others sources of
truth should I explore to verify this
rarely do we find things that are binary
and where people fit on the spectrum is
challenging and dedicating metal
resources to better understand ourselves
a society in this regard is generally
good idea so I credit the conversation
getting rolling and having us critically
think about it the attention cake is
zero some youtubers know this they know
they need to stay relevant they are not
selling product services like
entrepreneurs they're selling video
content and merchandise mostly so them
acting wild in cases to give viewership
shouldn't really be a surprise and
neither should the people at home hungry
for this content because people also
like watching more dangerous unsafe and
thrilling content now when people's
rights safety is put at risk in harmful
ways without consent that is very
dangerous it needs to be better address
there's a lot more to unpack here I
think this is a nuanced driven and
relatable start so remember a couple key
points people land in all different
places on the spectrum some are
problematic some are challenging
societal constructs everything from
maverick sociopaths Psychopaths
megalomaniac problematic and also
challenging societal constructs remember
it's not binary it's a massive spectrum
the attention cake is a zero-sum game so
people are being radical to get larger
slices of cake and make money
be vigilant scrutinize this and feel out
how we can best address the issues we
are seeing arising but also amplify the
people that are doing good work huge
thank you for tuning in much love go
build go create go and manifest your
destiny much love thank you
[Applause]
[Music]